Те, про що так багато говорили, сталося:
колишній канцлер ФРН Ґергард Шредер не лише
увійшов до ради директорів "Роснефті",
але й очолив її.
У Шредера вже солідний послужний список у російських компаніях.
Не встиг він піти з посади канцлера в 2005 році,
як очолив комітет акціонерів Nord Stream AG -
компанії-оператора трубопровoду "Північний потік".
Саме Шредер, ще на посаді канцлера,
лобіював будівництво цієї магістралі.
У 2016-му Шредер додатково очолив раду
директорів компанії Nord Stream 2.
До цього він встиг попрацювати незалежним
директором в ТНК-BP.
І ось тепер нова кар’єрна віха: голова ради директорів Роснефті.
Зарплата 73-річного Шредера, в разі його обрaння,
без вирахування податків складе щонайменше півмільйона доларів.
Які ж функції у голови ради директорів російського енергетичного гіганта?
Він веде збори акціонерів, веде раду директорів.
В усьому іншому він, власне, є таким саме членом
ради директорів, як і інші. Це просто такий модератор.
Ну, плюс, як правило, це залежить від компанії
і конкретної особистості,  він у більшому або меншому обсязі
здійснює різні піарні функції, дипломатичні функції.
Він працює більшою чи меншою мірою,
так би мовити, на зовнішній світ.
Нечаєв вважає, що Шредера беруть на роль такого
собі міністра закордонних справ Роснефті,
який буде працювати з іноземними партнерами.
Адже концерн має багато проектів за кордоном.
При цьому експерт припускає, що якихось суттєвих важелів впливу
на роботу "Роснефті" у глави ради директорів не буде.
Його найголовніший важіль у цьому сенсі -
це сказати, що він не згоден з якимось рішенням і,
мовляв, якщо його далі проштовхуватимуть,
піде у відставку.
Інших варіантів у нього немає.
Решта - це переконування, аргументація, якісь емоції тощо.
Цікаво, що в Німеччині дещо інакше сприймаються
повноваження голови ради директорів.
Так, німецький співрозмовник DW,
який раніше працював у Москві
і побажав залишитися неназваним,
відзначає, що роль у такої людини радше почесна.
Він не втручається в оперативну діяльність підприємства.
Рада може брати участь в довгостроковому плануванні.
Рада не укладає договорів.
Разом з тим, він може брати участь у виборах членів правління.
Але центральна його функція - контролююча.
Він стежить за тим, щоб керівництво
компанії не порушувало встановлених правил.